depuis un mois et demi à follainville
dennemont dans le nord des yvelines les
gendarmes sont présents le mercredi
après midi au moment du marché dans un
local prêté par la mairie et le
reçoivent les habitants on accueille les
plantes
lorsqu'il ya des dépôts de teinte on
renseigne les personnes lorsqu'il ya des
questions puis lorsque c'est un peu
calme on en profite pour faire une
patrouille au contact de la population
sur le sur le marché devant leur local
accessible aux personnes à mobilité
réduite une banderole gendarmerie
nationale a été installé cette
initiative permet de rapprocher les
militaires et la population la
philosophie d'amo hausse est également
de réinstaller donc la gendarmerie dans
cette fonction qui m'est très chère de
service public on est véritablement un
service à la disposition du public alors
suivant l'angle répressif quand
évidemment il faut l'être mais également
on doit être là me semble-t-il en appui
en conseil en bien veillance pour
écouter les gens cette présence permet
aux personnes non véhicule et d'avoir un
poste de gendarmerie plus proche que
celui de limay à 5 km elle rassure et
crée aussi du lien social
on remarque avec nos anciens une grande
solitude
toutes nos activités habituelles ne
peuvent pas se dérouler il y avait
beaucoup d'inquiétudes de la part des de
nos aînés et voilà le fait de pouvoir
exprimer leurs difficultés qu'ont
rencontrées par cette proximité c'est
très important des autres communes aux
alentours profit du même dispositif à
drocourt et fontenay saint père un
premier bilan sera établi courant avril
avec à terme l'objectif de l'étendre